so yeah about three people have asked me
to do a video on this but damn it I want
to talk about this as those are my kind
of three people all four of us are gonna
gush this movie might be crap but it
might be rad trailers like Robocop meets
Iron Man but he doesn't get an iron suit
he just kind of gets Jarvis in his head
and it all turns him into John Webb
classic case if this guy's wife was
killed they probably intended to kill
him only he didn't get killed he lived
so this dude's like what if I can give
you something that can make you walk
again like that show mantis from the 90s
well now he has a voice in his head
there's like Jarvis he's like oh wow and
the Jarvis not Jarvis Jarvis is just
like oh by the way through the power of
the Internet here are the ones that
killed your family
here's the address so he goes there to
take him out and then he gets his ass
kicked
so I'm hot Jarvis and his head's like oh
we can take control if you give us
permission he was like permission
granted
and then holy the trailer starts
the up he is beating dudes died
just like how effective he looks
everything is pinpoint precision the
camera movement itself it's just a great
visual way to illustrate what's
happening using the camera as a device
for the scenario it's smart and fun he's
busting plates and over this guy's
head in his face is like oh my god I'm
not even doing this it looks like he
pops his head off like a desert even
says I need to keep you alive like
essentially if you die I die which I'm
wondering if they're gonna go a layer or
two deeper with that at what point is
the dudes motivation going to conflict
with the microchip in any movie where
there's someone or something trying to
save someone sometimes I have to save
someone from themselves so at what point
is a dude like no I'm gonna do this in
microchips like shut down I don't know
not ever happened this is the kind of
unbridled fun unapologetic fun a movie
could be is a revenge tale those aren't
always awesome I was there for the new
Death Wish we've seen revenge tales of
people without chips in their spines and
in their head so let's just see it with
I had such a good time with John wick
because I just love it when someone is
so efficient at something that's
something being you know ending lives I
guess it looks like a fun spin on that I
mean this movie could be asked if it
bricks it if it it up if it shits
the bed oh my god I thought it'd be cool
but of all the trailers I could talk
about I just kind of want to talk about
this one right to the trailer to upgrade
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]